ces trois engins de chantier ont été
incendiés dans la nuit de dimanche à
lundi
malgré le couvre feu les violences dans
le quartier du maïs se poursuivre
un couvre-feu qui ne semble pas
convaincre les habitants
moi je pense qu'une bonne chose je me
suis pas sûr que ce soit efficace que ce
soit suivi mais c'est sûr que l'on
utilise les mineurs pour pour faire des
bêtises parce qu'ils sont pas
répréhensibles par la police
judiciairement quoi donc le fait qu'un
couvre-feu ça peut changer 12,6 et
respecter les lois et puis le respect
des lois ça c'est une autre paire de
manches
tout a commencé au début du mois de juin
durant plusieurs nuits des incendies se
multiplient
des policiers et des sapeurs-pompiers
sont même pris à partie face à l'urgence
le maire de chenôve instaure un
couvre-feu pour les mineurs à partir de
22 heures
ils n'ont plus le droit de sortir seul
nous avons souhaité donner ce cadre ce
cadre juridique supplémentaire pour que
la police puisse agir puisse
éventuellement interpellé des mineurs
isolés
donc non accompagnés de leurs parents ou
de leur représentant légal sur l'espace
public de le faire raccompagner à son
domicile par la police ou que les
parents viennent chercher ses enfants à
l'hôtel de police avec cet arrêté
le maire espère une présence plus forte
des forces de l'ordre les syndicats de
police saluent l'initiative mais déplore
le manque d'effectifs on a des textes
réglementaires qui nous permettront de
faire le protéger ces mineurs de les
contrôler et les ramener au service de
les mettre en sécurité de ne pas les
laisser sur la public seulement
accompagné par contre notre problème ce
sera avec quels moyens de faire parce
qu'on n'a pas d'effectifs
supplémentaires c'est les mêmes
effectifs qui sont amenés à travailler
donc la nuit à effectuer des patrouilles
de sécurisation des interventions police
secours et les effectifs là ne vont pas
être
ne vont pas été augmentés en lien avec
cet arrêté municipal après sens et
montceau-les-mines chenôve est la
troisième commune de bourgogne avoir
décidé d'instaurer un couvre-feu
il sera maintenu jusqu'au 14 juillet
inclus